i'm mack walters and i was the lead
writer i'm aspect
ii today uh we're gonna be talking a lot
about the development of our dirty dozen
characters that
uh were so integral to mass effect 2 but
obviously to that huge suicide mission
that we did at the end
some of the things that we did to make
you care about those characters
and really weave their story and their
narrative
into that that epic outcome of
the second game of mass spectrometry
this legacy party members dock
is a living document that we would have
used i'm going to say
probably from about three months in the
development uh
up until anywhere from six to nine
months going into end we realized
you know our biggest challenges was
going to be coming up with
who are these 12 iconic characters who
uh you care about enough to bring to
your party
and go on a suicide mission with i think
one interesting
thought that we had early on was that we
couldn't just make
12 new characters that were disposable
part of the trilogy was this idea
of your consequences going from game to
game so we we knew it was going to
however this suicide mission was going
to play out it had to feel consequential
you know you can see lots of different
ideas for
various characters in here and honestly
early on we
very much kind of went with that there
are no bad ideas
idea for coming up with um
pitches for the different characters at
this point we wouldn't really
necessarily even be thinking about
how they would interact with each other
or even maybe how they'd interact with
the player
um we really just were trying to throw
things at the wall
and see what would stick and there's a
lot of uh really fun
characters in here that eventually
didn't make it for one reason another
although i'm sure now that they're gonna
be out in the world people will be
clamoring for some of them like the uh
you know the crazy korean king
i i honestly can't remember whose idea
that was so reading it it feels like it
was probably cruz
um but yeah this idea of the
craze someone like the crazy irishman
from braveheart kind of just a fun
you know wild bombastic character you're
a madman
another interesting one number 16 the
mad bomber um
you know this demolitions expert that's
just
crazy and you can kind of see elements
of that morph into
a bit of the convict but i also think um
in some
some degree uh elements of that also
blended into zaid eventually just this
sort of crazy bombastic person obviously
drastically different characters in the
end uh jack
and zaid but you can see the inception
point of some of those in here
owen and of course we had a techno
hippie at one point anyway
so that was a thing further down in the
document you can start to see
uh i guess i would call these sort of
our early top picks but even these
you know weren't final by any stretch we
have um
you know this solarian assassin sounds
really cool and with the
sort of the inspiration from an ingo
mataya and i think that's an interesting
point there even is that
it might seem obvious but you know we
take inspiration from
everywhere i always love the princess
bride i love that character
my name is you kill my father
prepare to die another interesting shift
and
and change is in the corian infiltrator
that we see there
and it honestly was until i went back
and read this that i even remembered any
any of this sort of early inception of
it but it was a reference to butch
cassie and the sundance kid that kind of
caught my eye
and i realized that a lot of what we see
in this sort of character details and
their sort of plot line
ended up morphing into um garris and
specifically into the archangel but
honestly early on that
that's what we're looking at is just
getting those ideas out there because
you don't know
what's going to be interesting and as we
go a little bit further in and further
along you'll start to notice as well
that
it's often not one idea that survives i
think that's something that's really
true about a lot of
game design a lot of storytelling is
that this concept of oh it's one big
idea and that's what makes a great game
it's like no it's it's thousands of
ideas and a lot of times
they do start to all blend and weave
together as you go throughout and
and it was really interesting for me
actually of course being separated from
this now by almost 10 years going back
and i had forgotten
how much these characters had morphed
and evolved over time and kind of
blended into each other
you know you can see hints of characters
who would
later become much more defined so a good
example would be
14 crusader uh at this point you know
this this is a male
and they're just called new alien we
knew we wanted a new alien race
involved in mass effect 2 we didn't know
what they they would look like we didn't
know
how they would behave and i remember
having probably half a dozen meetings
just on
who are the dwell what are they called
we didn't they were called the drill
at the time and so it is an evolution as
we go through and each of these things
tend to feed back into each other
another good example here you know if
you go to 19 you see
we included garris we also had tally in
this in this uh early
version of the document i think you know
we knew we wanted some of those key
characters from aspect one to be coming
back to be part of the dirty dozen we
weren't sure which ones we weren't sure
how we were going to do that um if this
truly was a suicide
mission what did that mean for you know
the beloved characters of mass effect 1.
you can see really clear starting points
for
what would become miranda there's
usually a kernel or
some sort of thing a spark for a
character
and you can almost always trace that
back right to the the origin here right
and that
concept of not just miranda's plot
points
and the fact that she worked for servers
and things like that but there's sort of
this idea that she was genetically
engineered that
made her perfect that that was also
going to be her flaw
and that's kind of that spark in miranda
that thing is really interesting and
that that remained all the way
throughout and
and to me you know that is us
telling stories about characters that
are fast is when we we
find what those those things are and we
make sure they stay true throughout
another fun example to me is the design
of krogan
3b when i worked on garrus on
mass effect 1 one of the things i really
enjoyed about his character was
his malleability the fact that this was
a character who
was waiting in some regards to be shaped
by
by a strong figure i like that idea and
i think the design of krogan sort of
kind of grew out of that concept in the
in a way that
what if you took that all the way to the
start like actually
you know from birth almost and you can
really shape that character
so the concept of the dirty dozen
and of the suicide mission was something
that i think we kind of hit on fairly
early
in a world where consequence and choice
are so integral what's
what's more consequential than taking
all those characters you love and
putting them in a suicide mission right
and you can even see
in this document we start to refer to
things in in sort of bold when we don't
know what they are
at this point we just knew that one day
you'd be assailing this this
planet this fortress whatever it is and
a bunch of people would die if you
didn't play your cards right one of the
interesting things that we always joked
about
you know on a friday was a suicide
mission
with you know 10 or 12 of your favorite
characters
is creating just the most brutal future
world for ourselves
on mass effect 3 because now you've got
all of these permutations that we're
we're going to have to deal with and and
we would all just laugh and say oh
that's for our future selves to worry
about
and we did figure it out eventually it
was uh
we knew it was coming we knew the pain
was coming you know it's interesting at
the bottom of this document where we
look at some of the
again the top pick so you can see that
we're starting to
flesh out the relationship uh
specifically how each character's
relationship with
shepard um could go it's interesting
because you can start to see things in
here where we're starting to talk about
loyalty
and how that could potentially impact um
you know the characters and their and
their arc um
a good example is under the young thief
it's like if if the loyalty doesn't stay
up then they'll leave
i don't think at this point we had fully
figured out
um how loyalty would impact the
the end game but we knew that it was
going to be an important factor it
wasn't just a matter of
find you know 12 people um
and go attack things like no um it's
actually going to be about interact with
those 12 people
they're not going to want to work well
together in fact
some of them might even want to kill
each other and if you don't do something
about that
you're going to fail the mission i think
we also realize that a lot of games
don't necessarily want to address the
fact that you know
the people that you're hanging out with
all don't get along and and to me that
just makes them feel more alive like of
course
some of these characters wouldn't get
along of course they'd hate each other
of course they'd even want to
kill each other or leave if you don't do
something about it and it kind of
also spoke to sort of that you know
leadership that comes with
you know the burden of being being
commander shepard in this case
can i actually get all these people to
work together towards a common goal
so we don't all die in the end and to me
i don't think we
knew how powerful that would be um
we guessed and and i think it worked out
really well in the end
in this second document we're going to
look at we had narrowed in on you know
what our top characters were going to
look like really start to flesh out some
of their stories a little bit more
and and try to really figure out not
only what their narrative would be but
how was that going to work in the game
and i think what's interesting
in this document is you can see that we
have now identified that there are
loyalty
missions and there are acquisition
missions we knew that we wanted to
center
a lot of the actual missions that you
would go on the actual levels of the
game
around these characters obviously that's
going to be important and then we would
divide them into
those two steps first you acquire them
and then and then you have the optional
one
to make them loyal you'll notice that
dane was actually creos then
and it was at some point who knows when
uh i would have decided no let's
actually
call him dane creo you know we're really
starting to flesh out
um you know the missions um as we're
going to
acquire these these characters but also
a little bit more detail about who they
are and what drives them their
motivations
but even at this point you'll notice
like we don't call out things
like capital syndrome for thane uh we
knew that thane was
dying that was part of his motivation
and that was going to be what
really sort of drove him and meant that
you know he
would both be willing to join you and
help you in this mission
uh but also kind of made him a really
unique free agent right
you know a lot of times there would be
characters that we might have just
written a small you know sort of side
quest for
and uh the great thing is too is you can
also you know
in the case of like a common burner you
can kind of go oh wow
fans really responded to that let's
bring them back i'm commander shepard
i should be able to deal with that
person uh or see them dealt with and
that's how
uh you know i sort of had the idea to
bring the santa back in this one because
she wasn't
the best person in any one to deal with
and in fact actually kind of gets one
over on
shepard if i recall in any one so at
this point we've come quite a way and
we're actually detailing out the
different points
and we may simultaneously even have what
we would call like a great box
uh level uh at this point so very rough
this one
uh gr loyalty so that's garris loyalty
so we've
already acquired garris at this point um
who was
archangel and i think we know one of the
interesting things if you
if you actually look at his acquisition
uh documents there is no mention of
archangel at that point i don't remember
what point i went you know what would be
great is if we could surprise
the light players a little bit and
actually you know
have them think they're going to get
this cool uh
sort of renegade character named
archangel
and it turns out it's garrus and garris
has had
a lot happen in that time and we can
then sort of unpack all of that
that's what made you know these missions
so much fun to do and i think
probably what made them so memorable for
players as well
and then this whole mission just sort of
reveals all this interesting stuff about
them and to me i think that was
that was one of the fun things about
doing you know these missions when we
started writing the idea of the suicide
mission it's immediately apparent that
obviously you know the characters would
be critical to that um
especially in a game where a choice of
consequences matter
as much as they do and on you know at
the end of the day if i haven't written
a character that
that people care about don't want to
save well that's on me
so really as a writer my goal is to to
make you
make you care and make you want to save
that character and invest
the time that we take to uh you know
acquire them make them loyal keep them
loyal
um and then make sure you know of course
in the end you do the right thing
we knew that it had to be centered
around the characters it's a suicide
mission
their lives had to be at stake and that
we had all these sort of inputs that
would tie
into um that we wanted to be more
more complex than that so there were all
these
very very uh distinct inputs some of
them loyalty missions some of them are
on conflicts some of them around
um whether you did um you know some of
those missions right at the end
when it came to actually executing that
sort of final story
it's also obviously super important that
you still want to bring it to
a conclusion that feels satisfying and
feels like it fulfilled the promise
of what you set out to do beyond the
idea of
uh you know this was going to be a
suicide mission
it was also we knew it was trilogy so we
um you know specifically casey had
always wanted this to be that darker
middle act you know
the empire strikes back of our trilogy
and
you know what could be darker and almost
more
tumultuous than you know an ending where
you don't know the outcome right like
it it could really change everything as
far as your perspective is
is concerned on what's happening in the
world how you're going to proceed in the
next
act right and i think that's why
again you know that the suicide mission
fit so well
within that concept you know to me
what's
interesting as i sort of went down this
sort of nostalgic trip and tried to
remember what did we do and how did we
do it
there were times where i was surprised
that i'd forgotten because it had been
an amazing project to work on we didn't
know all the answers
we didn't know that this was going to
work out and honestly even if you took
all of those same people and said do it
again
i don't know i don't know if we would
sometimes magic strikes
and you know if you could point to it
and go that's that's how we did it that
everyone would be doing
that's part of the magic of it is that
it was a very
um uh quick project to work on we didn't
have a lot of time to sort of
second-guess ourselves and honestly to
me that
that's the magic of of that experience
having worked on it
and and hopefully that's you know part
of the magic that
people still remember from